[Music]
looking at the object obtained in
relation to this whole sphere we see
that the actual world of culture was
summed up in the vanity of
self-consciousness into a being for self
whose content is still that confused
world of culture and which is still the
single individual notion not yet the
explicitly universal notion but returned
into itself that notion is pure insight
pure consciousness as pure self or
negativity just as faith is precisely
the same as pure thought or positivity
in that self faith has the moment that
makes it complete but perishing through
being thus completed it is in pure
insight that we now see the two moments
as absolute being wich is simply thought
or the negative and as matter which has
positive being this completeness still
acts that actual world of self
consciousness which belongs to the vain
consciousness the world out of which
thought raised itself to itself
what is thus lacking is obtained and
utility insofar as pure insight there
attains there acquires positive
objectivity pure insight is there by an
actual consciousness satisfied within
itself this objectivity now constitutes
its world it has become the truth of the
entire preceding world of the ideal as
well as of the real world the first
world of spirit is the widespread realm
of its self dispersed existence and of
the self certainty of its individual
forms just as nature disperses its life
into infinitely various forms without
the genus of those forms having an
actual existence the second world
contains the genus and as the realm of
intrinsic being or truth over against
that certainty the
third-world however that of the useful
is the truth which is equally the
certainty of itself the realm of the
truth of faith lacks the principle of
actuality or the certainty of self as
this particular individual but the
actuality or the certainty of self as
this particular individual lacks
intrinsic being in the object of pure
insight both worlds are united the
useful is the object insofar as
self-consciousness penetrates it and has
in it the certainty of its individual
self its enjoyment it's being for self
self-consciousness sees right into the
object and this insight contains the
true essence of the object which is to
be something that is penetrated by
consciousness or to be for another this
insight is thus itself a true knowing
and self consciousness has equally
directly the universal certainty of
itself it's pure consciousness in this
relationship in which therefore truth as
well as presence and actuality are
United the two worlds are reconciled and
heaven is transplanted to earth below
with paragraph 581 we are now finishing
up this very short subsection the truth
of enlightenment the true thing you
could save our own of enlightenment and
we're also finishing up that section on
the Enlightenment and that means that
we're actually quite close to finishing
the entire section on culture in this
massive spirit portion of the work so
we're actually at a very important
turning point and we want to do a little
bit of retrospective looking back and
that's part of what's going on in this
this paragraph Hegel is doing some
summarization and and and some you know
reflection on how we got to where we are
we want to deepen that a bit beyond the
actual text here because he's being very
summary in it and and I think it's an
important point for us to pause and look
back over all that we've covered in this
this pretty large culture section you
notice that before that we had an
earlier section on the ethical order
which was a bit shorter and and led then
into the realm of culture and then we
had all of this stuff going on within
the culture section and then and then we
had this dialectic that we've been
playing out now for commentary after
commentary paragraph after paragraph of
the relationship between faith and
insight both of which are forms of as
Hegel's calling it pure thought both of
which are coming out of the culture and
transcending the the cultural
problematic as Hegel has has elaborated
it for us but also remaining attached
you might say by a kind of umbilical
cord to that very world of culture
because that is the world in which faith
and pure insight still have to
exist and even if they're going to be
preoccupied largely with battling with
each other or insight you know getting
the upper hand during the Enlightenment
in its critique of faith it always
remains within these worlds and we're
going to see Hegel talking about three
worlds at this point by the end of this
paragraph worlds of spirit and this
should you know make you think back if
you've been following along with the
entire work of other sections where
Hegel has talked about multiple worlds
inter penetrating each other for example
the discussion of the inverted world in
relation to the the non inverted world
and then there was a third world there
as well in the force and the
understanding section so remember
something again before we get to the
text Hegel tells us at multiple points
in this work that as we move from
earlier sections to later sections there
is a process of however we want to
translate Alf hey bong or you know Alf
Haven in the verbal form whether we want
to say sublation which is not a word
that really means all that much or if we
want to be a little bit more cumbersome
but a little bit more exact about a
transcendence and reintegration that's
another way of thinking about it that
has been going on so all of the earlier
forms what's really essential in them
all the earlier shapes of consciousness
all the earlier dialectics they're being
brought into these later sections so
spirit the one that we're in right now
and getting fairly close to the end
we'll talk about that in just a moment
where we actually our spirit is in some
respect more concrete more actual more
view click more real than the reason
section which was already quite real
then
the self-consciousness section than the
consciousness section think of them as
being telescoped into each other and
transformed in the process by the way in
which they are integrated with each
other so this is a really key point now
I mentioned that we are close to
finished with this this spirit section
so what we have ahead of us is the last
part of the culture section which is
called absolute freedom and terror and
it's not very long its paragraphs 582 to
596
spirit that is certain of itself
morality and that itself is not that
large of a portion in comparison to what
we have traversed so far we're looking
at from paragraph 596 to paragraph 671
and then all the rest of the work except
for you know the tiny little bit of
absolute knowing is the large religion
section that we're going to culminate in
so you know we're a good ways through
the development of spirit the
development of mind the development of
Geist's what was most concrete you could
actually end the work there and shave
off the religion and absolute knowing
section and you wouldn't lose all that
much except for the closure point
perhaps and the the very interesting
discussions of religious life in the
process and some commentators have seen
that as a good idea so where are we and
how far have we come let's go back to
this this paragraph 581 he says looking
at the object can
obtained in relation to this whole
sphere what is the object obtained we
just saw in the previous paragraph that
self-consciousness rational
self-consciousness has attained a self
understanding of itself through the
useful as the useful as something that
is for itself in itself but also for
another it is grasped itself objectively
gig and Stanley that is as an object
it's not fully integrated yet but it is
grasping what it is in realizing its
place within a larger framework if you
want to call it world or culture or
society so Hegel says looking at this
object in relation to the whole sphere
we find the actual world of culture was
summed up in the vanity of
self-consciousness what does he mean
summed up there well remember at the end
of the first section of this entire
culture portion we had
self-consciousness rational
self-consciousness practical rational
self-consciousness trying to figure out
where it fit in not only in terms of the
rest of the world and social roles but
in terms of moral values was it the
noble consciousness or was it the base
consciousness was it split between the
two if it's not the noble consciousness
who is where can it find it there was an
alienation a insanity a
compartmentalization that had taken
place at the end of this section Hegel
talks here about vanity about things not
being able to be fulfilled at that point
what we see along the road of the
dialectic is a number of places where it
appears that oh we might have a
resolution we might actually have
finished we might have reached the end
and it never turns out to be such so
this entire discussion about faith in
enlightenment came out of the vanity of
the worldly aspect of culture of
building right so he says that it's a
being for self whose content is still
that confused world of culture and which
is still here's a really interesting
line the single individual notion the
single individual peak if a person
trying to figure out again like what am
I where do I fit in
what's my role am I sort of at the edge
of what's important what's victus right
what is essential or am i at the center
is my consciousness determinative of
what is but then if it is why is
everything so screwed up why don't
things add up why don't they make full
sense so he goes on and he says it's a
single individual notion not yet the
explicitly universal notion and then
Hegel says returned into itself that
notion that becomes pure insight pure
consciousness as such negativity its
counterpart faith is the same as pure
thought or positivity so we have faith
is being used in different ways maybe we
have thought we also have being we just
saw that in the previous several
paragraphs but there's some sort of
determinate content their faith has an
object a transcendent object that that
in relation to it says I I don't matter
as much right I am consciousness and yet
there's something greater out there
beyond that I ought to in some way
connect myself to and pure insight says
well that's very interesting let's look
at this let's let's examine let's
analyze let's see whether these things
really do add up faith what are you up
to and we don't have to go through this
whole discussion again because we've
just passed through paragraph after pair
raph of insights critique that is what
the enlightenment is in part now notice
that the enlightenment itself is
dependent to some degree on faith as
something it can push against it can
gain some traction it's not just a
critique of culture it's not just
leaving faith behind it's the interplay
between faith and insight that matters
here so he goes out and it says in
fittin in that self faith has the the
moment that makes it complete but faith
perishes through being thus completed
and we we've talked about that and the
Enlightenment historically is a time
when at least for some people the faith
of the past something that in fact was
transcendent that went beyond you know
religion that was just based in culture
think about you know traditional
greco-roman religion we had a
transcendent conception of God and our
relationship to to God through rituals
through a church through whatever you
want to say people found that to no
longer be sufficient for making sense
out of the human relationship to the
divine and the understanding the self
understanding of what the human is or
could be faith winds up you might say
evacuating itself in the period of the
Enlightenment coming after the
Reformation in which we have this
proliferation of different exciting new
viewpoints and counter responses on the
part of the the older Church all of that
in the Enlightenment becomes seen as
vain so he goes on and he says this
completeness the completeness that faith
had still lacks that actual world of
self-consciousness which belongs to who
to the vain consciousness aha this is
where that stuff that we thought we'd
left behind comes back right the person
of faith the purse
of insight they still live in a world
whose basic traits and structures are in
fact still described by those earlier
dialectics those earlier shapes of
consciousness that you know constant
interplay between social classes and the
political class between service on the
part of the noble consciousness and
appropriation on the part of the base
consciousness between the city and its
demands and the household and its
demands and the gods of the household
also resisting that all of that is still
to some degree in play and it still as
screwed up and muddled as it had been
before because these still have to exist
within that world so Hegel says this is
a world out of which thought raised
itself to itself it's possible to do
that right it's possible to transcend
that world what's going to be the case
now why does Hegel then talk about three
worlds so here's the transition point he
says what is the slaking lacking to what
lacking to these two by themselves faith
and pure insight insofar as they are
outside of the world and yet still
anchored in the world the world of
culture insofar as it doesn't fully
understand itself and can't iron out its
its contradictions what is lacking is
obtained in utility this concept that
we've been exploring and which is going
to be important in in the next section
utility insofar as pure insight there
obtains positive objectivity he goes on
and says pure insight is there by an
actual consciousness satisfied within
itself this objectivity now constitutes
its world a new world is being generated
I don't I almost said created No
being generated is being generated out
of the other world again think back to
the force in the understanding section
the inverted world was generated out of
the world that we perceive and that we
attempt to produce laws about that have
something to do with the forces there
right taking into account us the the
observer and we generate another world
which is not we shouldn't imagine these
as sort of like side by side with each
other they inter penetrate each other
the world of utility is the world that
we live in now reveal to us in light of
utility it's a different world but it's
also the same world just viewed in a
different way that becomes possible
according to Hegel for pure insight it
wasn't possible for faith faith was too
preoccupied with its own objects it
wasn't possible for the self
consciousness the various forms of
self-consciousness including the final
one the one torn against itself right it
wasn't possible for them to arrive at
that point either it is possible for
insight and insight now in understanding
itself is proposing to everybody else a
vision of the world a vision not only of
the world but of their place within it
this is something new this is something
revolutionary so Hegel says this
objectivity now constitutes its world
the world of insight the world of the
Enlightenment it has become the truth of
the entire proceeding world of the ideal
as well as of the real world
notice that Hegel is already talking
about two worlds there and talking about
insight at its grasp of utility becoming
the truth of both of those worlds
so now Hegel actually tells us
three worlds first world the spirit
second world of spirit third world of
spirit how are these connected with each
other again think back over the sections
that we have traversed first world the
spirit II says is the widespread realm
of its self dispersed existence and of
the self certainty of its individual
forms just as nature disperses its life
into infinitely various forms without
the genius of those forms having an
actual existence what are we talking
about there we're talking about
individuality we're talking about
something that Hegel at one point called
the spiritual animal kingdom everybody's
got their thing that they do their
project none of them actually connect
with each other we can generalize about
things but you know for the most part
they they they pursue their course and
there is no sort of overarching let's
call it ideal that incorporates them
right there's something similar at the
beginning of the self consciousness
section Hegel says just like life
dispersed itself into all these
different kinds of individual lives and
we could say what did they have in
common well they want to eat each other
they want to survive we're gonna ask it
that that juncture what the hell is the
point what's what's going on here what
what really matters and the answer is
well to the individual their thing
matters but there's no larger context
noting that Hegel would at that point
call truth there is self certainty I
know if I'm doing that that you know I'm
a cobbler cobbler is my thing and I need
to make some money so I can eat and make
some more shoes and you asked me well
where do you fit into the society I
don't know is there a society
I'll let somebody else figure that out
that's somebody else figuring that out
the the political class or the religious
class or whoever the intellectuals
they're grasping the second world he
says the second world contains the genus
the gotten and and I put genus here into
the plural because I mean it should be
got going in right but really we're
talking about multiple Genesis multi
poll forms of forms right we have all
these different forms of life and
somebody actually has to sort them out
and think the big questions you know
this is the playdough saying well how do
people comport themselves some people
are driven by this other people are
driven by this other people are driven
by this maybe those correspond to parts
of the soul we can have all different
theories about this this sort of thing
that is grasping people and their
projects what motivates them what leads
them into action into their relations
with others in terms of what he's
calling genus here don't get too hung up
on the biological notion of genus
because that's not what he means he's
talking about some sort of ideal reality
and the fact that we can actually work
with that that Hegel says we go beyond
that the third world that of the useful
it is the truth which is equally the
certainty of itself he says then he says
the realm of truth of faith lacks the
principle of actuality the certainty of
self is this particular individual
individual the actualities or the
certainty of self with this particular
individual lacks intrinsic being being
in itself Anzhi but in the object of
pure inside he says both of these worlds
are united and they're brought into this
third world says the useful is the
object insofar as self consciousness
penetrates it and has in it the
certainty not just of the object but he
says of its individual self its
enjoyment it's being for self self
consciousness sees right into the object
and that includes not just seeing into
other objects part of a world or other
people part of a shared world but also
into one's self and realizing that one's
self is an object not only for one's
self but for others one is useful just
like all these other people for somebody
perhaps for everybody
perhaps for the world
right so he says this insight is a true
knowing self-consciousness has equally
directly a universal certainty of itself
it's pure consciousness in this
relationship in which therefore truth as
well as presence and actuality are
united isn't that nice it looks like
we're actually at a resolution point
aren't we as opposed to culture earlier
culture where we didn't have a
resolution point where everything was
all screwed up
and now notice how Hegel ends this
section the two worlds are reconciled
the ideal and the actual the world of
certainty the world of truth and heaven
is transplanted to earth below heaven
the heaven of faith the heaven also of
insight is transplanted to this world of
utility sounds pretty good how is it
going to play itself out that's what we
need to turn to the next section to see
but of course the title kind of gives it
away absolute freedom sounds really good
and terror
you